a participant asked for some tips on the
backward five beat weave and we're gonna
break it down like this face this way
with me okay you're gonna take your left
paw you're going to spin it backwards
and you're just going to bend your
knuckles like you're checking but bend
your knuckles towards your arm a little
bit and what that does is that means
there's a lot of space between your arm
and your and your wrist and the spinning
poi that's kind of the secret or that's
how I do it you can take your right poi
you can just dip it down in that space
and this you know take some plane
control except first the plane bends
it'll catch your other point so you have
to play with it a bit until you can let
the poi even swing a little bit and it's
swinging in between your arm and the
spinning toy from here on one of those
swings I can let the right poi catch the
left wrist and lead across to the right
side and what's important is that the
right poi leads but you don't actually
need to pull that off successfully to
make to get the progress here really you
just need to make some progress with
this getting used to that space you can
reverse it do it on the other side where
the right choice bends backwards and you
get used to the left poi being in
between your arm and the spinning poi
you can try letting the left poi catch
the right wrist and lead across and
that'll get a lot of the right things
happening in your brain hopefully then
you try it from spinning poi and both
poi to spin backwards on their own sides
and I can pick okay I'm going to try on
my left side so my left hand back
and I've got all that open space the
right poi comes over hooks and pulls
back the biggest obstacle at this point
will be your muscle memory because what
might happen is you come over and the
left boil just want to lead because
you've done the three-meat weave for a
long time and that's what you need to
get past
now that's partially why if you start
from here it can be helpful cuz you've
already broken the pattern a bit and
you're starting from somewhere weird
and from here you go kay the right leads
the right leads right leads and that can
be a good way to get a new habit but
it's really weird so maybe try from you
know alternate from starting from
swinging and starting from both boys
spinning backwards the royboy leads over
and hooks the left wrist or the left boy
comes over and talks to the right wrist
if I'm helping somebody through this
I'll often just hold instead of them
spinning the poi I'll just hold it and
then they can't pull it across and while
I'm holding it I'll say okay spin the
other poi come over and hook the wrist
and I'll let go at the last minute and
it'll make them lead with the hooking
POI so those are the best tips I've got
the POI you know if I'm coming from the
left side I just go this way with my
wrist just that is all it takes and
putting it all together it looks like
this the right hooks and leads the left
hooks and leads the right leads back to
the right side and the left leads back
to the right the left side I guess the
last thing I'll say is the other hand
thumb down so look at my right my right
orange POI I come across thumb down
because that's the way I can kind of
wave to myself around the wrist and a
way to practice that maybe you can just
let the say the left play hanging it's
been the write and practice that motion
or with no point at all just practice
the rate comes hooks under the left
wrist you want as much wrist to wrist
action as possible to help
the right boy lead over vice-versa
were the left pie hooks and curls to get
under the right wrist hope that helps
I'll try thinking some more tips if it
doesn't